you guys are from texas right you two
are from texas right where are you from
well i'm from dallas texas but i grew up
in a small town
called little elm yeah yeah i know where
that's at i'm from fort worth so oh okay
yeah yeah so um no but my whole side of
my dad's
family is over there so that's awesome
where are you from well i'm from dallas
kind of fort worth area
um i'm from a place called grapevine but
i think
i know grapevine yeah from grapevine
yeah and um think something went
i can't remember what it was but i used
to sing in grapevine yeah that's so cool
i think that my grandparents though they
live where you're from
assistant yeah that's where my birthday
i was drawing
yeah i'm from i grew up um kind of half
and half fort worth and burleson yeah
yeah that's so crazy i love texas women
i love you too we go back to isabella i
love you we do we go
[Laughter]
but um so what do you miss about texas
though that you're out here i miss queso
and chips
oh you know what my mom would make some
bomb queso but you know
okay well look at her number yes but um
i mean i love
everything about texas really um i kind
of miss the weather though
and you know it kind of see i kind of
felt like it was god's hair dryer in the
summer
like yeah but like my skin was clear my
hair was all luscious
like you know it was it was nice over
there but i mean um
i also missed the food obviously like
papados yeah i mean that's like all over
the south i love that you know pompano
papados is it like we we just went to
texas not too long ago and like that was
the first place we went with
papadopoulos
i know you hit your spots yes yes yes
definitely what about you
oh well i mean i really miss my family
but
there's also the food yeah i think
that's what every texan says
yeah it's it's really i really miss like
getting sweet tea everywhere and queso
and i i i miss so specifically i miss
cece's pizza even though i know that
it's not the best in the world i like
their mac
you just said cece's pizza mac after
church
every sunday when i was a kid we would
get no joke
they had this dessert pizza it had like
powdered sugar and like a choc and i was
like this is the best thing that's ever
happened to me
and jesus and uh yeah and i was but it
was every sunday i was excited about
jesus and that
dessert pizza um that's amazing i love
that you said that
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever